hey youtubers this is gonna be my arrow
episode 18 video they totally did the
thing there's all kinds of stuff we need
to talk about I'll explain the
characters death and what's going to be
happening going forward there's a lot
more happening than you might know about
even if you completely disagree with the
choice the producers made at least they
didn't do the Walking Dead thing and
completely yank our chain going into
season 5 they dealt with it in this
episode so now the other characters that
are left can react to it and move
forward or backwards depending on how
you think about it the promo for next
week's episode does make it look like
Diggle goes backwards just a little bit
but just to be clear before I do top
five WTF earth-1 Black Canary is dead
she's not coming back in the future of
the show but she will be seen again
during flashbacks later this season so
before the end of season 4 we'll see an
earlier version of our Black Canary and
then we'll also see Katie Cassidy as
another version of The Black Canary on
the flash from earth-2 I'm doing a flash
bonus video tomorrow I'll explain what's
going on with earth to Laurel Lance
she's a different metahuman version of
Black Canary so it should be a lot
closer to comic book Canary and the
producers did explain that Sarah will
learn about the death on legends of
tomorrow in a future episode and they'll
deal with her reaction on that show so
top five WTF starting with number five
Oliver learns that 40% of the voters
wrote him on to the mayoral ballot so if
something were to ever happen to Ruby
Adams damien darhk's wife there's at
least 40% of the voters that would be
totally cool if he took over so just put
a pin in that for later mayor Oliver
Queen I think is gonna be part of the
season 5 plots depending on where they
go with it at the end of this season but
she's effectively mayor now that's how
she's able to take the current DA put
him in her cabinet then offer the job to
Laurel but number four WTF Andy
seemingly comes clean about Merlin's
involvement in how he's tied up with
high of Stowe
based on the scene with Merlyn last week
and the way he was acting in this
episode it was pretty clear that he was
a double agent sigil was just drinking
all the kool-aid they take down the arms
too easily
Oliver very much in the right to not
trust Andi but his issues and really
great stunts Merlyn vs. Thea Laurel for
obvious reasons gets one of the best
fight scenes that she sat all season but
number three WTF this was a lot of fun I
haven't even started to torture you yet
I was really hoping we get to see at
least a little bit of that torture
because he definitely deserves to be
tortured now
diggle pulling the gun on oliver is
definitely not gonna win him some fans
the producers did explain and they kind
of already tipped their hat to it in the
teaser for the next episode Diggle more
than Oliver is guilty over laurels death
he blames himself in a way that Oliver
doesn't do anymore they've already had
that scene after the funeral where
Oliver's like I don't blame myself
Diggle does not have that moment he
definitely blames himself and goes super
dark apparently at least for a couple of
episodes number two WTF cry havoc and
let slip the dogs of war
also slipping an arrow into laurels body
and assets that it had to be one of
Oliver's arrows so now damian darhk--
has the idol
he's completely repowered and dark
remains a man of his word as he says to
Laurel which is kind of a freaky thing
to say as you're killing someone so we
got to say it it totally sucks that they
killed the Black Canary but I am really
happy that they stuck to their guns
because as he says part of Quentin's
deal was that if he betrayed damian
darhk-- he'd kill laurel quentin
betrayed him so laurels dead now pretty
simple but the problem is is that a lot
of people will want Quentin to be
punished you could look at this a number
of different ways he's gonna have to
live with his daughter's death number
one WTF is actually like the first part
of his punishment in that he doesn't get
there in time to see her before she dies
and we also got to talk about the
promise that she extracted from Oliver
but Quentin what is he gonna do now that
laurels dead I mean he's still going out
with Felicity's mom so she might help
him a little bit but he's already a
really dark person to begin with is he
gonna start drinking again if someone
else does not punish him the way he
feels like he deserves to be punished
for what he's done he will find a way to
punish himself but because he's a cop
this is a superhero show he might also
go the Diggle route and just get super
hardcore what about that promise that
Laurel gets out of Oliver what was that
all about because they cut away we
didn't hear it
there's a couple ways to think about it
one it's more of a metaphorical promise
like promise me that you won't go to the
dark side you won't start doing things
like damian darhk-- would do them you're
not going to start killing people again
the other option is that it could be
some secret that's going to help Oliver
take down Jaime and dark for good
without having to kill him but in all
the flash-forwards we've seen after the
funeral Oliver's like I know what I need
to do now I need to kill him even
Felicity is like you need to kill that
son of a [ __ ] so let me know in the
comments what do you think about the
death even knowing that Laurel Lance is
going to exist on earth too
we'll see her in flashbacks so
technically she's dead she's not gone
completely they haven't fridge the
character in what do you think that
laurels promise was just to talk about
the episode on a technical level I feel
like they paced it really well it was
really kinetic the energy was high they
kept the momentum there weren't any
weird scenes that dragged the momentum
down I feel like if they could get to
the point where all the episodes of
arrow could move this way it would be
perfect really like the last scene
between Oliver and Laurel where she's
like I'm not the love of your life but
you're always going to be the love of my
life
nice hat tip for earlier times before
Oliver went and had sex with half the
women on the show and if your big comic
book fan it's a nice hat tip to that too
but I will say for people that are just
super pissed that she's killed off the
show they killed the Black Canary you
can't have green arrow without Black
Canary that's kind of a literal
interpretation of where some of the
comics have gone not all the comics but
but a good portion of them all say that
this version of Laurel Lance was never
really the comic book version of Black
Canary
for me she was always kind of like the
wired version of Black Canary not like
you would expect on the flash with like
you know full-on comic book personas and
metahuman powers speaking of which
earth to Laurel Lance will be way closer
to comic book Black Canary although that
won't technically be her name she'll be
called the black siren that I'll totally
explain what's going on with that during
my flash bonus video and they did say
they would probably do an episode in the
future where all of her meets earth to
Laurel Lance but it won't happen this
season he's not going to be in that
episode of the flash that Laurel is
going to be in but just to reiterate the
producers did explain pretty extensively
about why they chose her to be the one
to die off they were really just looking
for the character that would provide the
most WTF for their characters and drive
them forward going to season 5 it had
nothing to do with behind the scenes
politics or any crazy things like that
so don't don't believe that there are
any conspiracy theories about why Laurel
was the one to end up in the grave but I
almost forgotten all the craziness there
is a new round of the DC giveaway this
week all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave a comment on this
video it's just a $20 Amazon gift card
it'll be open till I post my last DC
video this week so hopefully that'll
make you feel a little bit better I
could probably spend the rest of the
night talking about you know what arrow
did tonight but I've already kind of
fried my voice why you guys wait for my
next video you can click here for the
Star Wars rogue one teaser and you can
click here for my Civil War
behind-the-scenes video thank you so
much watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys